[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about everyone off the
record
stuffy nose Joe I love it those nice
though I saw that you went to China oh
yeah I went to Shanghai man they asked
about a couple of you guys I don't know
who trying to say Shanghai as accurately
as you can son I
it's a shanghai did you do stand-up out
there yeah in Chinese oh so what blows
my mind is oh is it for the expats or
the how do they do they have a
translator like I just imagine you doing
some comedy I would there's a mic so the
jokes are delayed by a second there's a
dude translating your code and um show
ever
awesome punchline he has to wait for the
translator
yeah and then nobody laughs twice middle
laughing the do buddy he's hella funny
star is born that's a great scene from
ooh great way to start a movie because
then he needs me didn't the next thing
he thinks he can do it on his own bales
yeah and the sink is high for him you
know do they have people who do a sign
language for that commie I remember that
or I don't know how comedy does remember
that one lady that she's my role because
of Snoop Dogg's concert she does a lot
of rap concert she goes you should get
in on it I think white lady but I've
never seen it at like a stand-up show
like where those a sign language person
does not be dope oh that's a great idea
but it was cool man it was interesting I
mean the Chinese people I said somebody
picked her nose feed it to a cat
Oh for me it was like the exact it was
the best example of China because they
nothing is like waste of everything just
goes forward it's like whatever I got
this I'm not hungry oh this guy's hungry
we got the we got to keep going let's
keep going good what's the [ __ ] China
really dude we got cats handy everywhere
a lot of progress people just moving for
it and people Pro chine to do this
people are about you can't even get a
passport you can't get a passport there
you can't get a um citizenship oh it's
really hard right I'm wondering why you
were here but we did an article about a
guy in Florida he married like a Chinese
lady and then he became a Chinese
citizen you were like wow there's so
many Chinese people trying to come to
America and your ass is going over there
to be cometary citizen you also have to
give up your citizenship from wherever
you are you can't have duel see yeah I
just literally picture this guy going
there and he goes to like the embassy
goes I want to be in a why and they
laugh right go away you have the other
way around
he'll already knows he just wants to
feed all the cats I want to be a open a
breeder I brought the bait countries
while you're out there no I went to some
town called shaman shaman I was like a
beach community kind of it's pretty cool
and they're Chinese lifeguards oh man if
China's your first experience of Asia
you went to the wrong place man was that
your first experience no I've been
somewhere else I'm not sure where though
all right but it was awesome it was
great you went to Thailand or something
you told us about the you tried to save
a pigeon I mean you went to set it free
and someone else caught it in Vietnam
yeah
at the bentback market yeah is it good
enough you said Thailand they're not all
the same yeah they're not all the same
my memories bad I'm sorry what the [ __ ]
Riverside is not the same as it's pretty
close yeah Encino but they had yeah we
bought this pigeon to set it free from a
market cuz this is market in Vietnam you
could pay for like a pig or pork they'll
[ __ ] pull that pig out from behind a
hug and tired us kill it right there you
know you get that hot Pig you know so I
bought this this pigeon or something
this doves look like a dove I thought it
was like a peace bird you know like I'm
one of those Church Birds yeah yeah
Church set it free you know I'm saying
I'm giving this thing back you know this
one's gonna get away like this one's
gonna get out of China you know or
Vietnam this one escaped Vietnam right
it's a good communism yeah it's about
one bird's journey to escape Vietnam
that's what Buddhists do you know that
oh really did a monk kind of thing
somebody uh I got one mom because what
happened was I literally go outside I
have like this moment I said it for the
second it hits the air a dude comes by I
could have been on a motorbike right
this Vietnamese got a little like our
best but that could really jump someone
would like dessert hands just [ __ ]
yes dessert has broke snapped its neck
threw it on his back a very little man
right through his back and went straight
home with it damn so as soon as it made
fly it was I bet a family good for you
you're still giving him a gift
yeah thank you very much thank you my
man foolish
it was wild though man we do in Vietnam
but yeah I liked it I was just here and
up there translator's again yeah school
yes selling mice not stand up show up
there I know is this a student are you
doing like staying abroad yeah um I
don't know X I ended up getting a degree
in something I think Town Planner urban
planning playing SimCity yeah civil
engineering yeah basically yeah it
sounds like you're lying to us about
your degrees your get your story
straight
I mean it definitely there's a lot of
you know misinformation out there but it
was cool man I said everybody gets
diarrhea there could instantly yeah yeah
oh they took us to a place like there's
a lot of times if you come in and you're
white or if you're like European then
they will take you to a prostitution
type of place replaced with a sex for
sale right did you do that no oh well I
didn't on purpose
okay okay good story cuz you know what I
went into this place and then she just
started sucking me off and I was like it
is what it is all you have to do is tap
her on the forehead but you just
couldn't stop it yeah where's the ice
cream feels good I can't get it up I'm
like oh this is a rocky road
what happened was so they just take you
there and I don't have any issues of
prostitution I think prostitutions you
know I don't look down on it or anything
like that if it's a business it is what
it is but the place they took us to was
a pet pet store so you go in and there's
all these birds and stuff like this and
I was like oh that's pretty cool this
guy took us to a pet store you know who
would think of that it's a neat thing
you know and they had like three like
big parrots or some type of you know a
you know kind of viewed pretty birds you
know they're talking Birds bar yes
speaking Vietnamese they were talking
Birds I don't know if they they knew a
little bit of a little bit yeah but
always having a beignet oh my god
[Laughter]
reserved that one so but then in the
back they had prostitution going on and
it was just a front the pet shop is a
front who would have thought so I've
seen I mean my buddy's end up back there
my buddies are trying to get [ __ ]
you know and I'm like way nervous and
like it go I'm trying to negotiate the
way said nobody gets a [ __ ] and I
still pay right so that's kind of where
I'm at like here just take a couple
hundred I'll get it I'll hang out with
the birds
but then the birds started saying like
sexual stuff that they'd heard happen in
the back of know like oh yeah like a
[ __ ] it you know [ __ ] hard boy you
know like crazy Mexican parrot forget
our date
it's an international international
brothel that sounds about yeah they were
saying like there was a couple of terms
I couldn't run what they were and then I
got scared man I got really really
scared and I left out but that's great
my friend's mom she told me like in the
Philippines like if you get a massage
and you get a new fart
that's like a compliment because it
means they're doing a good job oh wow
you're so relaxed like they're so
relaxed that you fight that like the
business is like you're doing a good job
I'm gonna do that at Koo Koo Roo next
time let's get a farc no it's at a
chicken shop chicken restaurant Koo Koo
Roo gonna fart out of [ __ ] Koo Koo Roo
yeah they massage you there no it's not
massaging is just for food but then you
get like oh I thought you guys were
Filipino you get as far told us that
like in there today in the Philippines
when you get a massage and you part it
means you did a good job and they feel
good so if you don't fire they're pissed
and it's like this one with sisters in
the corner nobody party I don't have the
magic hands anymore if you fart it's a
compliment because she means she's doing
a good fart fart then they're gonna
[ __ ] change their mind that she's
smoking while I didn't know that I'm I
don't I mean that's what she told me so
I believe it I believe it I'll dude I
guess yeah you could fart in another
country I guess I'm not gonna fart in
America because nobody cares if you do
it here we gotta save all your farts for
overseas then no we care a lot yeah but
I want to go where people really care
Philippines yeah where people feel good
about themselves if you fart you don't
want to be shamed yeah here's the
shaming country for sure to be looked
down upon if I [ __ ] rip ass and Anna
McDonald to play house what a compliment
someone which are far yeah yeah yeah
walk like some guy had a nice suit walks
mine I just fart and he's like three
piece I just
I just did a road trip from Sacramento
from LA to Sacramento like it's not a
road trip this is driving somewhere you
know it's not seven hours bro if you're
Asian roat's three hours of your mother
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] long but how's that
a rest stop it's like Barstow that place
is that death bars that's the way into
Vegas is it barks oh is it Barstow no
Buttonwillow I'm sorry stop Buttonwillow
that place is a [ __ ] hellhole dude it
was like a hundred and ten degrees and
everybody looked like dead that's
basically California though you got the
major cities and everything in between
is like [ __ ] you drinking bad this
risk it's the thing that throws me off
and there's another restaurant that we
stopped that called it was like a P P
Anderson Anderson or something like that
right and then they have a restaurant
that just serves pea soup Oh [ __ ]
serve no no it's Anderson's pea split
peas yeah good that [ __ ] looks like barf
and [ __ ] yeah yeah it's bombed though
it's good yeah it tastes decent right
but the thing that threw me off that
every time I I was there I did not
expect my waiter to be a fabi Chinese
lady I thought was how did you get here
like what was the story that got you
here yeah I mean it is Diouf tea right
she just said that she was like what
were you like
channeling Bobby Lee right there's a
grab or shoulder be like we used to we
used to play basketball with a bunch of
uh
like Chinese and Malaysian fobs right
and they would come in and out like oh
you used to play with them remember when
we used to go play at that cat basically
what they'll do is they'll get a work
visa and then they'll come to the to the
states and then they'd get the most
money going to these like restaurants in
the middle of nowhere and doing work
there for a couple of months and then
going back to Asia or whatever when
their visa runs out so they I don't know
they have like a circuit of restaurants
that just need people like a job agency
or SAS I know places have nothing they
just have the
the rest stop which is the gas station
the Carl's jr. than McDonald's the
subway and the dens and that's it
everything else is death and suicide I
always wondered worthy my god yeah like
whenever you see like a gas station in
the middle of nowhere and or like a
little restaurant you're like we're the
there's no homes around there I'm like
were they how do they live underneath
tell you about see what style bro bro
these people in the ground and power
like you ever drive to Mammoth mm-hmm
and then on the way there you'll just
see a little house out of nowhere with
like a with some broken cars Oh broken
cars are sad we're like where you get
rusted ass cars right in your like where
do you get your groceries yeah yeah it's
in the desert you can't grow anything
people dude yes bro that's Book of Eli
[ __ ] there the spleen dude Oh
spleen again what do you do for food
dude and that is how they get new food
rows and people keep curiosity bro I'd
be scared to live there because like
there's probably gonna be like help my
car's broken down at 2:00 a.m. and then
BOOM [ __ ] hitchhiker are you talking
snack yeah you seem like something
somebody mediate Thanksgiving as well
they gotta [ __ ] eat me like an egg
roll you have an apple in your mouth on
the [ __ ] bed or the dinner gross yeah
you would be a seasonal treat I bet
that's just scary
imagine getting eaten dude what would
you say right before they eat you
these alive is not dead even alive you
get my last words and I got tied up
you're about to they're about to you in
the oven maybe I mean it's yeah it's
like a [ __ ] Lobster yeah bro and even
know what my last words would be man I
just it's all over I mean I'd be like
I'll suck your dick
I think I'll exit my body to give them
like another option right no fighting
chance I'll suck it all they call sex
slave if you want to switch it yeah
because I'm already tied up right so I
call sexual
[ __ ] cooking you on a bed bro in your
mouth I'll suck your dick I'll do
something I'll be your slave I'll clean
a house yeah clean clean is good
you need something up service you know
that's not a good idea dude if you say
you're gonna suck their dick that just
mean yourself basting that's it all
that's true yourself basing your summer
oh he's like oh we're like a glue and
your [ __ ] fantasy when you're getting
cookie of a ball gag in your mouth and
[Laughter]
eat cooked bro stick that thing in your
[ __ ] butthole oh yeah to see if
you're done almost think it boiled like
like in the movies you know the witches
that are like they're rednecks and they
gotta stick a can of beer and first put
you in the oven that'd be cool at least
you get a buzz make it a 44-ounce
Japanese cannibal oh yeah yeah he killed
somebody in Switzerland or something
like that spice did a video on it worse
in volunteer right no no no he was a
what do you call it like one of those
study abroad students out in a country
in Europe and in one of his uh study
buddies he decided to kill her and in
save her and in just [ __ ] eat her
body Oh snacking and then he got in
trouble and then he got extradited to
Japan but under Japanese law he couldn't
be prosecuted so he just was living free
and now he's a five-star chef in Japan
yeah there's like a five year waiting
list it was like this whole thing and
they were asking him about what his he
was explained what his he knew what he
did was wrong well so it wasn't like he
didn't know but he just kept talking
about what his favorite part of the
human was well worth a people think he
was like the butt or something but she
was too much fat you want to eat like
the thigh he goes are the best part Wow
the [ __ ] guy's insane is it illegal in
Switzerland and Japan or is like the
Filipino later it's good too far over
yeah
I know that humans illegal in Japan too
but I think the law made it so that the
crime wasn't committed within the
borders it just didn't work out but this
fool looks [ __ ] weird man he looks
like a skeleton with skin nothing else I
think he got executed recently though I
think he did it again or something Judy
Heumann ribs I think so man ribs are
[ __ ] good bro I love ribs are pretty
good do you like beef ribs or baby backs
or in st. Louis or like I think all of
them really I've never been like guys
ribs aren't really for me my favorite
has to be beef roast but they're hard to
do they're hard to do well yeah [ __ ]
big and it was a lot of fat yeah
pork ribs dude my god suck the meat off
a [ __ ] pigs ribs any babies and
that's crazy to think you know people
say I'll never blow a dude but not damn
boy I'll [ __ ] take the [ __ ] tongue
the lean meat off of [ __ ] pigs ribs
all day you don't saying is not there's
not really a fine line that's very fine
line that's true yeah especially if
there's 12 ribs dude it's way less Gator
just below a guy you know I realize how
big pigs get like those industrial bit
like the ones that we eat those ones
that a manufactured real quick Galapagos
what are you talking about those
industrial pigs your other ones you
can't pet for $5,000
those ones I'm talking about those ones
that are the size of this table like oh
[ __ ] yeah if they use like those
barbecue competitions yeah they're like
a solid like four hundred pounds it's a
fair yeah I didn't know they're big
they're so fat though they can't even do
it can't even stand yeah they're always
sleeping and [ __ ] the disgusting dare
because there was like that thing where
people were buying like these like
teacup pigs right but they're not even
tiny like teacup pigs are still like
this big when they grow like yes eyes
like they're still size that with a
Labrador it's crazy we're still eating
like eating pigs kind of a lazy thing to
do like it's not hard to catch you know
wild pigs are [ __ ] hard that's true
that's a good point
now wild pig ribs dude that would be
good II have the time
I have not many of them I'm down to try
it Joe Roby to do that [ __ ] he'll hunt
anything Joe wood dude yeah
that man is a hunter all he's always
ready to hunt he's setting things up in
his yard all the time and it's ready
just bow and arrow something down
somewhere they can afford to have some
you know something you could shoot a
bear Oh boss continually more muscular
as he gets older like he's just getting
buffering most poor heads pretty buff
yeah his head it's so funny to them you
can see like the progression because I
used to be a huge I still a fan of his
but it used to be on that show what
radio he was on a sitcom oh yeah
yeah when he was doing USC commentating
he was like during that same time but he
was on a sitcom called radio and that
was actually my first introduction 10
mmm seeing him evolve well there's now
this is in his early green his 20 it's
like in his early 20s and even Hollywood
for a minute yeah so he's been doing it
for a long last time and you see the way
he looks like his head got bigger and
[ __ ] he getting he's got but you look
like a thumb now
[Music]